conan it's wild backstage it is yeah
it's wildness back there is there
craziness back there oh yeah it's a very
unprofessional show here exactly there's
probably animals running around
backstage yeah strange outfits many yeah
yeah that's us that's us we really we're
like a circus here and it should stop
let's talk about you i want to get
started on a few things we've never had
you here on the show before it's great
to have you here i've been in the air
for 40 years we haven't had you yeah
how's it been going i'm 69 years old you
look good i was the gerber baby food
model and i'm doing well
uh you know it's hard to believe because
you've had such big success in film you
started out in soap operas i guess a lot
of people do right i started out on um
on as the world turns yeah yeah i played
uh
did you ever do a soap did i ever do a
soap what soap would that be
welcome to wrong town
hi everybody uh no i never i never did
the soaps no i did uh um i played betsy
stewart montgomery andropolis on on as
world turns
a lot of marriages a lot of failed
marriages right
um
uh
yeah she was the good girl of the town
it was a while ago now that i'm thinking
about it i did a sitcom here in this
building right right well i want to ask
so one of the things that fascinates me
about soap operas that i love is
at the end of every scene people do that
thing where they say something dramatic
and then both people just look at each
other
for a while and dramatic music starts to
play and you always think what an
awkward moment in real life you know
and it gets worse kind of throughout the
week so by friday even if it's a very
mundane sort of very non-dramatic thing
you have to really really have a lot of
emotion about it right so by friday you
know because they want people to tune in
on monday right so you could be very
dramatic about the oven being at the
wrong temperature or something like that
right i said 350 degrees what did you
set it at
and then they could freeze 3.75
and they can just hold it like that and
you really believe
they're so good my other favorite move
in soap operas is people embrace and
like i love you i love you too but one
of them knows something bad so they
embrace and the camera sees the one
person go i love you too
or like you're you're forever clearing
everybody's light and you work so much
you do it in real life too right you
know with your boyfriend you just get
out of the way of someone else's light
like all the time yeah now do you did a
sitcom you mentioned tell us about the
sitcom i did um
i did a sitcom here and then i did an
episode of charles in charge
you get a charles in charge
do you remember that show scott baio was
in that show one of the great theme
songs of all time do you remember it at
all
charles in charge of our days and our
nights
charles in charge of our wrongs and our
rights do you know a lot i don't know
what the hell that means how do you know
that charles is like some dictator
governing our emotions
how do you know that uh how do i know
that things stick in my head i know
things and i don't know valuable things
i really don't i don't know like what's
the largest landmass in the world i
don't know that but i know the charles
in charge theme
uh oh i have lots of themes i i can't
you know call them up just on the moment
now i'm getting shy i can't do it f
troop i know that one do you yeah
not as apparent as charles in charge no
opera because it ends charles in charge
i want charles in charge of me it ends
on this like big kind of like
which is very
i'm the dancing monkey on this show now
do this conan all right
tell us about this film this film was
about uh boxing and you actually took
boxing lessons uh are you a fight fan at
all am i a fight fan i went to the
fights once uh and i thought it was
actually pretty cool it's just that i
was invited but it's you know it was one
of those things it was weird that you
were invited yeah that anyone would
invite me anywhere it was so strange for
me it was also free i'm a bit of a cheap
skate and uh so if i'm invited someplace
i go
yeah yeah well now what was your feeling
about it i thought it was uh much more
dramatic than i thought it was going to
be because you can actually hear
the gloves hitting the bot it's it's
very visceral it's very powerful very
electric and if you're sitting close
enough you get sprayed with all kinds of
stuff
what
that happens here too i don't know
um
no i had a good time i played the the
only woman who ever
successfully managed a middleweight
boxing champ she had six champions her
name was jackie cowan and she's a a real
a real piece of work
so and and you trained why did you train
if you're not playing a fighter why did
you want to train i trained because i
didn't um
i didn't know anything about boxing and
uh i i forever screaming things at my
boxer that i like i didn't know what a
jab was i didn't you know so i had to do
i i thought if i could at least put it
in my body if i could you know hit a bag
or something or know what a combination
was then i'd maybe be a little more
effective right because that way if you
you've got to learn what it is or else
your character's gonna be yelling bash
him with your fist bash bash him yeah
yeah it's a it's a wild world right
right so you uh so you learned and what
was your fighting style
well with my fighting style yeah when
you when you're practicing what was it
like i um i didn't really have a style
but because i did it for about three
weeks and you know no one ever threw a
punch at me right but i threw a punch at
this guy called benny the jet you know
he would teach me combinations and stuff
and yeah having me jump rope and thing
do you box at all i
like the old style i like to
i like to strip to the waist and then i
like to
do a lot of that and i like to have a
big mustache
and i like to use an office chair and i
just to go in and out like that yeah
long one of these and um the old
peekaboo i like that yeah
uh i'm an idiot no i should never
if i was ever in a real fight i would
die in seconds have you ever been in a
real fight have i been in a fight yes i
was in a fight actually a long time ago
i was in this yeah actually in south
boston i was in a fight once didn't last
long did not do well they carried me out
of there in a jello bowl it was uh
um but uh yeah i even forget what it was
about i can't remember what happened huh
it was all traumatic yeah we guys you
know we like to get into scrapes i sound
all tough now no wait i never do um
now we have a clip here from the movie
uh tell us what we need to know this um
i think is after the after jackie's
boxers played by omar epps has won his
first fight
so and they're in the the locker room
just after good let's take a look at
this clip from against the ropes
oh
that was beautiful that was beautiful
nice works on the jab did you see that
right hook felix did you see that that
was great yeah he did all right
oh
hold on hold on one second
listen whoever it is nobody acts
surprised that we want
it's not cool to be too surprised
you don't want to do that
uh against the ropes uh opens on friday
meg thank you so much for being here oh
yeah thank you so
everybody the fab much coming up we'll
take a break we'll be right back